Okay, in this section we're going to simply focus on lens file creation.
This is the latest thing that we need in order to actually do our lens file calibration.
Now the lens file stores the lens distortion parameters, camera intrinsics and nodal point
offset data along with the associated focus and zoom values specific to each lens to camera
combination.
Now let's just jump into the engine here and take a look.
Create the lens file folder that we created earlier and right click in the content browser
area in order to open up the content browser create events asset menu, move up to the miscellaneous
section and go ahead and select our lens file.
Once you've done that, rename it to lens file Zeiss 25 millimeter P3 and double click
it to open it up.
Now the lens file asset editor has multiple calibration tools for automatically populating
the lens file with calibrated data.
They are your calibration steps tab and the lens file tab and the calibration steps tab
contains four sub tabs for lens information, lens distortion, image center and nodal offset.
Now in order we are going to be using our lens information first and for that we want
to make sure that inside this you have viewport settings so you can adjust the transparency
here.
Typically it's set to 0.5.
Choose your camera and make sure you're using the camera that you want to calibrate with
in the engine to match the real world camera so that is our NDC cam black magic Zeiss 25
P and that makes sure our media source is already connected.
Now there is an overlay you can choose for crosshairs and adjust that as well and you
can use that for our image center but we're not going to be using that today.
Instead we are just going to focus on finishing our lens file creation.
So in the lens info under the lens information section you want to make sure that you set
up some lens info to identify what lens you're using.
So for this I'm going to use black magic and I'm going to go Zeiss and I'm going to call
this my 25 millimeter P3 because it's prime 3 lens.
If you have the serial number information go ahead and put that in as well.
If you have multiple versions of the same camera type your serial number is generally
going to help you know which camera you're actually using.
So if you have that information it's going to be helpful to get that.
Next you want to make sure that you modify your sensor dimensions and for the Zeiss it
is the 25.34 millimeter by 14.25 millimeter sensor.
So make sure that these match exactly what the settings are for your camera.
Now your image dimensions here are 1920 by 1080 that's what's coming in for your feed
so you don't necessarily need to make any kind of adjustment in there.
Now taking a quick look at our lens file panel this allows you to see our focus, our iris
and some of our other parameters such as focal length, distortion, image center and nodal
offset.
Additionally there is an option for ST maps.
ST maps here can be loaded in through this section.
Now back to our calibration steps you'll notice if I look down here there is no raw
fizz input there is no connection in here and there is no evaluated camera settings.
In order to fix that we are going to need to make sure that some of the options that
we have available in here that we'll come back to are connected.
So let's move back into the engine itself and make sure that our lens file that we've
created is available and able to be used inside our camera.
So I'm going to move up to our NDC asset here in the outliner and I'll move down to my NDC
camera here.
Now if I go in here you're going to notice that there are several options and available
functions that are in here such as film back lens settings etc.
But we're actually going to be tracking our fizz data so we remember we created a live
link camera controller for our Blackmagic ZEISS fizz and I'm going to click on that
and you'll notice I don't have a subject representation right now.
So my live link didn't actually remember my default source being connected into my camera's
subject representation.
So I'll save that when I finish here today.
But in order to get this to work just choose your subject representation for your live
link virtual subject for your Blackmagic ZEISS.
Now once that's done you'll notice that there are some options available down here including
camera roll.
And we go down to our camera roll we want to actually go down to our camera calibration
so you can expand them and see that we've got lens file picker and we're going to choose
the lens file that we've created.
Now I can pull this from the lens file that's available in here or I can just drag this
right in.
Now once that's connected if I go back into my lens file one thing to remember before
we go through here it should be noted that we only support spherical lens models at this
time and that you must match your physical camera sensor to the camera itself.
Once you're done here go ahead and save the camera information.
We'll come back and use this a little bit later when we do our lens distortion mapping
and from here we are ready to go.
Let's move into our lens distortion mapping and get started calibrating our camera.